[Music]
among the thousands of people still
without electricity there are small
business owners like anne and paul
morgan the quebec tea room in durham is
anne's retirement project and it's hard
work not helped by power outages
they've been off grid since yesterday
morning it happens quite a bit in quebec
the last time the lady said to me um i
need to
claim my insurance
so it wasn't helpful at all
and you didn't get any money no so
you're not hopeful this time not hopeful
at all
northern power grid will cover personal
costs like food and accommodation for
some who are waiting to be reconnected
but ann and paul worry about the loss in
revenue
customers
like to come on a weekend
um
we've been turning them away today
obviously and but it just affects your
footfall and and then you know people
are very polite but they're you know
i'm sure that they'd just be going
well where do we go now
storm malik hasn't just hit power lines
this scene is a terrifying demonstration
of its wind force
a couple of cars in the driveway both of
them pretty much written off
after
that huge tree that you can see there
behind me i think it's probably about a
hundred foot in height uh broke off uh
during the storm yesterday morning and
um
fell down onto the side of the house and
bounced off the side wall there and
careered through both of the cars um
so it's a it's a scene of utter
devastation i have to say um i was
pretty badly shaken all day all day
yesterday knowing how close that i was
to when it came down
a lucky escape but the storm has been
deadly and left others homeless it
completely tore off the roof of this
house in gateshead storm malik was a bit
stronger than was predicted really by
the forecasts
and as we look at
storm corey coming i suppose what we're
really keen to do is we can't really
predict it with great accuracy we think
it's gonna have a wider impact over our
region of the northeast and yorkshire um
but uh i guess the brunt of the storm
probably can be felt in scotland a bit
north of us so what we're doing is
making sure that we use the time between
malik and storm corey to make the best
use of that time available where we get
on our network and repair the damage
that's been done and get many customers
back on before storm corey hits us
it's already begun battering scotland
and the north of england with amber and
yellow wind warnings in place
for those still waiting for electricity
they worry fresh winds will hinder the
repair work or cause even more damage
becky cottrell sky news durham